y hoy en directo a vamos a Buenos Aires
donde inició el tercer foro mundial de
los Derechos Humanos un encuentro que
cuenta con la participación de
importantes figuras de izquierda como de
Evo Morales Rafael Correa José Luis
Rodríguez zapatero y Cristina Fernández
de kirchner la vicepresidenta Argentina
que viene denunciando una persecución
judicial en su contra conectamos en
Buenos Aires con natalio cosoy
corresponsal de France 24 natalio qué
dijo la vicepresidenta durante su
intervención
Hola Qué tal Buenas noches del partido
militar al partido judicial La amenaza
la democracia era el nombre que llevaba
este foro que tuvo lugar este día en
Buenos Aires y ella fue interesante
Porque hizo un repaso de la gestión de
su fallecido marido Néstor kirchner y de
ella entre los años 2003 y 2015 cuando
fueron presidentes y como durante su
presidencia según su perspectiva en la
economía se había había mejorado sobre
todo para los argentinos de situaciones
más vulnerables y había habido un
incremento de la equidad algo que dicen
que luego se perdió con su salida de la
presidencia y la llegada a la
presidencia de Mauricio macri ahora
también argumentó que ese ese cambio esa
posibilidad de dar es mayor equidad a
sectores de la población en Argentina
desde la izquierda en el país aunque sea
a la izquierda peronista es específica
del cristianismo eso es lo que ella dice
que motiva esto que llaman una suerte de
persecución judicial y el nombre que le
dan es el guerra judicial que dicen que
es una de la utilización de los
tribunales y los medios en causa que
ellos consideran injustos e injustas en
su caso también hemos venido siguiendo
en France 24 en español muchas de las
historias vinculadas con las causas
judiciales que tiene Cristina Fernández
de kirchner es importante aclarar que
este es un contexto muy favorable para
ella quienes estaban aquí eran gente que
la apoyaba no solo los participantes de
las mesas que presentaron sus palabras
en el foro sino también quienes estaban
escuchando desde los asientos del
espacio donde se llevó adelante pero
otras personas en Argentina por supuesto
no están de acuerdo con esta perspectiva
y consideran que efectivamente los
procesos al menos algunos de ellos sí
tienen razón de ser natalio que otras
intervenciones se produjeron durante la
jornada
bueno fue una especie de encuentro de de
la de las caras de las caras habituales
de la izquierda latinoamericana Ernesto
samper José Luis Rodríguez zapatero
español también Baltazar garzón estuvo
el expresidente correa de Ecuador y
todos hicieron una referencia aún más
fuerte a esta idea de lofra y de
persecución judicial Correa hizo un
repaso de lo que lo que ha sucedido en
Ecuador donde él dice haber sido víctima
de esta estrategia de lofa y todo se
concentraba mucho en hablar de cómo
Cristina Fernández de kirchner está
haciendo víctima de lo que ellos
consideran los es interesante Pues el
contexto de un año electoral en
Argentina en el que ella había dicho que
por lo pronto parecía no tener
intenciones de presentarse como
candidata a la presidencia no está del
todo claro cada pocos minutos quienes
estaban aquí en el lugar cantaban
Cristina presidenta Cristina presidenta
sus seguidores le están pidiendo que se
presente ella había dicho hasta ahora
hasta ahora que no Pero además hay un
argumento desde
desde su sector incluso de esa misma y
quienes presentaron en los paneles de
que está siendo proscrita a través de
estas causas judiciales algo que todavía
no está concretado de forma efectiva
porque las sentencias no son efectivas
Así que veremos Cómo Sigue avanzando su
posicionamiento político en este año
electoral